hola cómo te van esta vez tengo este
problema que está en el capítulo 5 y lo
tomé del libro coach try code y townsend
que se llama química y reactividad
química y por cierto estoy haciendo este
problema con su permiso y vamos a ver
qué nos dice el problema dice el etanol
c 2 h 5 o h lleve a 78 punto 29 grados
celsius y este dato creo que va a ser
bastante importante así que lo voy a
atrapar cuánta energía se necesita en
just en news ok para aumentar la
temperatura de 1.0 kilogramos de un
kilogramo ok de etanol de esta
substancia desde los 20.000 hasta el
punto de ebullición que bueno sabemos
que está a esta temperatura y después
pasarlo de estado líquido a estado
gaseoso a esa misma temperatura y
también nos dan dos datos muy
importantes nos dicen que el calor
específico del etanol líquido
2.44 por cada gramo kelvin y su venta al
pie de vaporización es ochocientos
cincuenta y cinco por cada gramo y bueno
este problema creo que va a ser muy
fácil resolverlo si lo dividimos en dos
partes la primera parte va a ser subir
este kilogramo de etanol desde los 20
grados celsius hasta los 78 puntos 29
grados celsius y para eso voy a utilizar
el calor específico del etanol líquido y
ya que lo tengamos justo aquí en esta
temperatura bueno pues ahora habrá que
transformarlo del estado del líquido al
estado gaseoso bueno entonces nuestra
primera parte y déjame ponerlo aquí
nuestra primera parte va a ser elevar la
temperatura del líquido y déjame
apuntarlo elevar
le bajaron ok la temperatura la
temperatura temperatura
durán ok del líquido de el líquido y
bueno sería muy bueno saber cuál va a
ser nuestro aumento de temperatura
líquido es decir de qué temperatura
vamos hasta qué temperatura vamos a
llegar y si te das cuenta empezamos en
20 grados celsius así que voy a ponerlo
aquí vamos a ir de 20.0 grados celsius
ok hasta hasta a bueno una temperatura
de 78 puntos 29 grados ellos que es el
punto de ebullición hasta los 78 ok
punto 29 grados celsius de lujo y bueno
ya que tenemos estas temperaturas sería
muy bueno calcular cuánto va a ser mi
cambio de temperatura es decir cuánto va
a valer del tdt del dale te va a ser
igual am
bueno pues la diferencia de estos dos es
decir 78 punto 29 menos 20 grados
celsius y eso es lo mismo que a 58
cuenta y 8.29 ok grados celsius estás de
acuerdo y ojo esto está dado en grados
celsius pero también puede ser que el
bid la razón por la que podemos hacer
esto es porque las diferencias en
escalas celsius y kelvin son exactamente
la misma cosa
de hecho la escala kelvin es sólo una
versión desplazada de la escalas celsius
si tú agregas 273 a cada uno de estos
números
bueno pues vas a obtener los valores en
kelvin pero entonces si tomas la
diferencia quiero que te des cuenta que
va a ser exactamente la misma de
cualquier manera que hagas esto la
diferencia va a resultar 78 punto 29
menos 20 grados celsius lo cual es lo
mismo que 58 punto 29 grados celsius
también lo puedo escribir en kelvin
porque nos va a servir utilizarlo en am
kelvin 58 puntos 29 58 punto 29
ok
que el vino y eso es muy importante lo
estoy escribiendo en que el vino porque
justo aquí voy a utilizar la temperatura
en kelvin esto cuando nos fijamos en el
calor específico por eso voy a utilizar
estas unidades para hablar de
temperatura y bueno entonces nuestro
cambio de temperatura es 58 punto 29 y
lo voy a poner aquí a 58 ok
punto 29 ok y lo puede escribir en
kelvin recuerda que solamente estamos
hablando de un desplazamiento y por lo
tanto la diferencia es la misma ya esto
habrá que multiplicarlo por bueno pues
por la cantidad de etanol en gramos que
nosotros estamos utilizando bueno pues
recuerda que nosotros empezamos con 1.0
kilogramos de etanol pero habrá que
escribirlo en gramos y eso realmente es
muy sencillo porque si yo tengo a un
kilogramo de etanol es lo mismo que 1000
gramos aunque aquí te podría confundir
un poco si yo pongo por ejemplo 1.100
kilogramos ok
etanol y lo quiero pasar a gramos bueno
pues habrá que multiplicarlo por sabemos
que 1000 gramos ok
miligramos es lo que tiene un kilogramo
un kilogramo ok y date cuenta de lo
siguiente nosotros vamos a cancelar esto
con esto y me va a quedar 1.0 entre 1 lo
cual es uno por mil entonces tenemos mil
mil gramos de etanol aunque en realidad
solamente tenemos tres dígitos
significativos esto hace que parezca que
tenemos cuatro pero realmente tenemos
solamente tres entonces a 58 punto 29
kelvin lo voy a multiplicar por am mil o
key por mil gramos ok ya esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por el calor específico
del etanol líquido que lo voy a poner
con este color el calor específico que
es este que tengo justo aquí el calor
específico del etanol líquido es 2.44 ok
2.44 mil por cada gramo que el vino
ok déjame ponerlo así a entre gramo
y está de lujo porque date cuenta que
esto funciona nuestras unidades si te
das cuenta aquí puedo cancelar estos
kelvin con estos kelvin y por cancelar
estos gramos con estos gramos y
solamente me voy a quedar con jules y
date cuenta de la gran ayuda que nos da
el calor específico del etanol líquido
que realmente lo que nos dice es cuántos
yus necesitamos para aumentar la
temperatura de un gramo de esta
sustancia en este caso etanol un que
elvin la cantidad de energía por masa
por temperatura y esto solamente para
elevarla un kelvin y ahora sí si yo
quiero hacer esta operación de aquí ya
sé que mi respuesta va a estar dada en
jules y bueno para realizar esta
operación puede sacar mi calculadora y
si traemos mi calculadora para camps ok
vamos a hacer esta operación 58 55 158
puntos 29 ok a esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por 1000 ok
ya esto habrá que multiplicarlo por 2.44
y ahora sí es hora de conocer la verdad
así que mi respuesta va a ser 142 mil
227 y como sólo tenemos tres cifras
significativas entonces habrá que
redondear los 142.000 jules tengo que mi
respuesta de esto es 142 mil ok
jules y ojo esto está padrísimo porque
esta es la energía que yo necesito para
aumentar un kilogramo de etanol de la
temperatura de 20 grados celsius hasta
78 punto 29 grados celsius o recuerda
que lo podemos pasar a kelvin si
nosotros le sumamos 273 a esto me
quedaría 293 que el bien hasta bueno 273
más esta cantidad en el bng recuerda que
el final la diferencia es lo mismo a lo
que voy es que ya tenemos la primera
parte la primera parte nos dice que la
cantidad de energía que nosotros
necesitamos para aumentar la temperatura
hasta el punto de ebullición del etanol
son 142 mil euros y bueno pues es hora
de hacer la segunda parte la segunda
parte ok
va a ser ahora pasar este kilogramo de
etanol que ya lo tenemos a 78 punto 29
grados celsius pero que está en estado
líquido
ahora habrá que pasarlo a estado gaseoso
es decir lo que nosotros necesitamos es
evaporar evaporar esta sustancia líquida
y para eso bueno pues tenemos que
agregar el calor de vaporización aunque
realmente deberíamos llamarlo y déjame
ponerlo con este color realmente
deberíamos llamarlo como en tal vía de
vaporización que es 855 yul por cada
gramo así que lo voy a escribir aquí
abajo 855.000 ok por cada gramo ahora
asumiendo que ya está a la temperatura
de vaporización asumiendo que estamos en
el punto de ebullición
esta energía extra por gramo tenemos que
agregar para que esto se evapore y es
justo están al pie de la póliza ción así
que si a esto lo multiplicamos por la
cantidad de gramos que nosotros tenemos
que son mil ok vamos a multiplicarlo por
1000 gramos recuerda que lo que no está
diciendo esto es que se necesitan 855 y
jules para que se evapore un gramo de
este etanol líquido y bueno si nosotros
multiplicamos esto me va a dar ante
respuesta cuánto bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que en 855 por mil 855 mil ok y
bueno fíjate que las unidades son jules
855.000 jules es decir date cuenta que
se necesita mucha más energía para pasar
del estado líquido al estado gaseoso
este kilogramo de etanol que lo que
necesitamos de energía para pasar este
kilogramo de etanol desde los 20 grados
celsius hasta los 78 punto 29 grados
celsius
es decir
punto de ebullición transformando del
líquido vapor utilizo la mayor cantidad
de energía y ahora sí es hora de saber
cuánto es nuestra cantidad total nuestra
cantidad total o nuestra respuesta de
este problema va a ser a la suma de
estos dos y cuánto es la suma de estos
dos
bueno pues hasta lo podemos ser mental
si yo tengo un 142 mil ya eso le sumo
855.000 mi respuesta me va a dar en
jules y bueno aquí al final le voy a
poner tres ceros y tengo que hacer 855
más 142 800 más 100 es 900 900 97 900 8
y 15 y 49 también y 5 y 2 es 7 997 mil
ok esto jules jude porque nuestra
cantidad de energía que por cierto esto
es exactamente lo mismo que pensar en
997 kilos o inclusive podríamos decir
que esto es casi casi un medio
si quisiéramos hablar en esos términos
pero bueno lo importante es que ya
tenemos la respuesta esto 997.000 jules
es la cantidad de energía que nosotros
necesitamos para resolver este problema